hey
it's us once again it's the side track
show yeah for thursday
yeah just checking in just checking you
know talking you people through the
pandemic
it's funny because it's we're like doing
uh daily updates but we
just want to talk about stuff other than
the pandemics only people are sick of
talking about
it you know i've talked to uh trina and
people from the show you know people
that listen to the show
you know they're in other states up
north they're scared some of them you
know
which i can understand it yeah you know
if you don't really have you know if you
don't really know exactly what's going
on and
yeah you know you can get sick but
it's not gonna be that bad we're we're
gonna say i'm just like i said yeah
it'll be changes and stuff like that
it's like yeah unfortunately some people
are gonna die and that sucks but it's
like
that's what life is it's well and one of
the things about it is that i try not to
worry about it and i think i've
mentioned this on the show before i try
not to worry about things that i can't
that i don't really have any control
over and this is
like the the very definition of
something i don't have control over so
much i'm like not working don't worry i
have control
he's got control i can
yeah well no no i can't control what
their situation is that's what i'm
saying i'm saying in my local
environment
i'm [ __ ] out of control yeah i can
mitigate it no i do actually we have
been home for
a few days but i do actually have to go
to the post office yeah tomorrow so
maybe i'll go like it
maybe i'll go in the middle of the night
when like nobody's there no just you
know
[Laughter]
put on some gloves or something yeah i
promise to glove something when you open
the door and just do the thing and just
come back out
i mean generally as long as you know and
you gotta like wash your hands and i'm
sure yeah
it is because just right you don't touch
surfaces i'm more i'm more worried about
touching surfaces that other people have
touched than
other stuff like that so it's not a big
population density around here it's
really not so that's
that's what i think that's why we're
probably because we're kind of yeah
we're outside of orlando but we're in
like a real suburban
area where people kind of like live far
apart a little bit you can control
anything stay away from other people
unless you you can't because of your
work yeah because a lot of people are
still got to keep people
moving you know but you know dude keep
washing your hands keep your face
covered try to
keep caught stay away from crowds uh
don't [ __ ] rub your eyes
stop [ __ ] [ __ ] with your face
yeah if you can stay home stay home as
much as possible just
let's just wait and see what the numbers
are and it's going to depend on where
you live
yeah that's going to be a big oh yeah
definitely if you're around new york
san francisco l.a chicago anything with
a high
population high density yeah
you're probably gonna get sick yeah well
like i said it's you know it's one thing
to get sick it's like i feel like you
most probably will not die from yeah
most people don't even know they have it
evidently they're asymptomatic
yeah mostly i mean because some people
get colds and flus every year
my basic understanding is that most
people that get this aren't really sure
that they have it it's kind of feel a
little bit like crappy and then it goes
away yeah
but then some people are real
susceptible to it you know depending on
how old they are and what their
condition
is yeah some people just feel like [ __ ]
you know what i mean
yeah i felt like [ __ ] couple weeks back
i thought it was you did yeah i thought
it was this
i don't know it was kind of early though
for anybody and we're not really in
a high risk area but we don't know we
are yeah we're not in a high risk area
but we don't know how many there are
here because they're really not testing
they're only testing the people that are
[ __ ] sick yeah you know what i mean
there's a lot of people that are sick
already just walking around
no problem so yeah well you know we
don't have the resources to
check everybody yeah like the test is
like [ __ ] uh
thirty dollars a ten a person and you
know imagine thirty dollars per person
yeah
they can't afford all that [ __ ] yeah and
then they're making up all these tests
out of the blue just out of nowhere well
and most of the time it would probably
be unnecessary
yeah they're gonna be fine most people
catch it they'll be fine you know yeah
but so we had a couple of requests for
topics to
talk about which you know we don't have
that much of a problem like because i
because i figured well [ __ ] we could
always like recommend
music or books or movies or something
like that if we couldn't think of
anything else but we did have two uh
requests of things to talk about on the
show so that's what we'll talk about
now first of all somebody requested i
guess because we had talked about
how we got baby cookie yeah cookie as we
call her
like about her origin story
yeah so somebody asked about the origin
story of our other cat
beijing i was uh i was at the barn one
time
yeah he used to he used to work at a
barn out here and uh
helping with horses and stuff you know
this is the english equestrian
they had this uh girls long before i met
you jenny had this girl
she ended up being she's that now
champion writer she's in she's in
england actually
and she's also i think she might be
training a little bit but at the time
she was
i think a senior in high school she was
getting ready to get out and she just
ran up to me
tom tom look at the kitty and i was like
oh that's awesome they go
they're gonna kill it and i said give me
that cat
no one's gonna kill this kitty
turned out she had some friends
that had a cat that had a litter there's
a bunch of animals in the house
and they couldn't that the cat that had
the litter wasn't fixed and it kind of
like an unexpected pre
pregnancy so they were trying to either
hand all the cats out or send them to
the pound to have them gassed
oh but she knew how to get me you know
tom they're gonna kill it
well that would work on me too just give
me it and i wouldn't even think about it
and it was on the day the first day of
the beijing olympics
yeah so i called her beijing so what
year was that no i can't even remember
2008 2009 something like that because
she's about 10
isn't she she's about older 11 years old
yeah no it's almost 2020.
yeah yeah about 10 about yeah she's a
middle-aged cat
yeah she's uh she's hilarious as far as
i know
she's a rag doll i think yeah she's a
rag dog
um just just from the way she looks and
the way she behaves if you ever wash her
and get a wet there's no mask
just she looks bigger she looks like
goes down and then she's just like a
little bitty skinny rat
it's hilarious because for a long time
because like i said he had had uh
beijing and she was
i think when i met you she was not a
kitten
i mean she wasn't like fully she's
probably but she was almost
you know she was still pretty big but um
so i'd always just thought it was just
big
puff like a big puff ball yeah because
she looks enormous and i did put a video
because remember when i was watching the
bathroom the other day and she was
rolling around because she was like
bleach yay because she loves bleach
smell
yeah and so i videotaped her and she
looks like gigantic in that video but
yeah the few times we've given her a
bath you know what i mean
it's like she's like that's just his
little baby and we gave her a lion cut
at one point i might have put that video
in one of the things too because that
was funny
well candace candace was kind of like a
kind of like a kind of like a florida
redneck
paris hilton that's what she looked like
she kind of acted like that
but what's funny is that beijing acts
like she's paris hilton they
i don't know that's what we yeah we call
it something but yeah that's that's
that's what candace looked like
she looked like paris hill well mostly i
call her princess fluff ass
and yeah and and [ __ ] cat actor like
a princess too
so just kind of stuck just because
because she's so fluffy like
from behind she has like this big huge
like thing of hair
she's kind of dumb too she doesn't she
doesn't really focus on anything her
eyes are just kind of
she's gotten smarter and she's gotten
older she's going to notice she and
she's a little less aloof
than she used to be and she's like more
vocal than she used to be because
i feel like before she was always just
kind of like [ __ ] you guys and she would
just kind of go and lay on a bed
somewhere
i thought she might have had maybe some
eye problems maybe she couldn't see real
well but now she can see
yeah she can see just fine because now
she just didn't make eye contact and
didn't
focus on anything and just was just had
real kind of spacey looking
airheaded it was like a paracel yeah but
she's kind of less like that as she's
gotten older
now that she's like 10 or 11. now she's
like a cranky
old lady kind of yeah and uh she has
very specific ways of expressing to you
like what she wants
if she wants to go out on the back porch
she will come in the room
and stand by the sliding glass door and
she will turn and just stare at tom with
her head
yeah over like that and just stare and
stare
and stare yeah and then finally tom will
get up to open the door and then she
goes
man yeah and flicks her tail otherwise
otherwise she wasn't quick enough she's
just kind of like this ghostly presence
that just kind of
comes in and comes out she's not doesn't
really have that's her personality i
want to say that she doesn't have a
personality
that is her personality she just tries
to disappear or vanish and then just
looks at you you know when she wants
it's weird but speaking of ghosts
somebody wanted to know about
the damn house that me and eric lived in
okay
i'm gonna i'll say some more [ __ ] about
beijing okay go ahead and say something
no i was gonna say one thing that she
does do though even though she's
you know kind of aloof most of the time
she likes to
sneak up on people every now and then
you never know you know what's going to
happen and you never know when it's
going to happen it just only happens but
maybe it'll go like three weeks and she
won't do it but then like you'll be
walking through the house and she'll pop
out from behind the wall she like jumps
up the wall jumps up the wall and tries
to bounce like a wall
and that's your head to try to hit you
right
and then and then runs off and like
yeah like she's laughing and every now
and then she'll try to do it but she'll
like
she'll peek around the corner to see
where you're coming you'll see her like
you'll see her
it should pretend like she'll see her
she'll be like [ __ ] and then she'll like
pull back like that so she is kind of
like
and another thing she does too we call
it her cargo cargo cult behavior
yeah it's weird and she does this almost
every night
it'll be in the middle of the night it's
usually two or three in the morning get
those damn [ __ ]
yeah and you and you'll wake up and
you're here and you'll hear her out in
the living room she'll be like
yeah yeah and you go out there in the
morning
and there's all they have like all these
little stuffed animals like a little
stuffed fox and like the little
like toys from nightmare before
christmas and stuff and there's like a
little path of them
yeah it's always like the same ones yeah
she likes particular ones there's i have
like a little octopus she likes that
and she's like in the spider stuff
spider yeah and she just like leaves
them out there and if you
we've caught her a couple of times yeah
she just sits there
fires at it and stares at it and makes
that call
it's kind of kind of creepy it is kind
of creepy i'm not really sure what she's
looking at
nobody knows what she has but every
morning when i get up because i almost
always wake up in here
baby cookie will sit there and just
watch at her like watch her like what
does she do
because baby cookie doesn't really do
that no she doesn't know what it is
she's just like what the [ __ ] is she
doing
i mean cookie plays with her toys in the
middle of the night sometimes because
sometimes i'll wake up in here jingle
jingle jingle do
like one of her little jingly balls or
something like going across the kitchen
floor
but as far as she doesn't do that weird
cargo cult thing with the toys where she
just like sits there over it and just
goes
like every night
but yeah so speaking of creepy somebody
asked about
uh your boston house because i don't
yeah
i guess we've you've mentioned it
offhand a couple times but i don't think
you really went that much into the story
all right after after i got back from
walter reed army hospital they start
my normal ets date was approaching to
get out of the army
and what was funny is that my best
friend eric at the time
his ets date to get out of the army was
like two days before mine
so we were getting out the same time
yeah
and a bunch of weird like coincidences
had happened
he lived in boston before at one time he
was from detroit though
okay he lived in boston he wanted to go
back to boston he was talking about it
over that [ __ ] like three year period
and just by chance at the time i had a
girlfriend from brazil who was living in
boston
all right so we got into our idea we got
the idea in our head that we would move
to boston
after we got out and he had this down
volkswagen jetta
i sold i wrecked a motorcycle and sold
off like a lot of the guns and [ __ ] that
i had or we traded and soldered them you
know
because really couldn't take them to
boston kind of guns that they had you
know
ak-84s which yeah there was an ak-84 you
guys probably don't know about that but
i had one of those
[ __ ] bunch of aks um pistols and
stuff
and i sold all that off and that's how i
uh
um got about and then the paychecks and
everything and that's
because you know i had my army paychecks
yeah and um
so i had enough money to move down there
so when we get there finally get there
and a bunch of weird [ __ ] happened on
that day that we left there was a mass
shooting
that was a weird [ __ ] time a dude
at fort campbell found went to the damn
massage parlor
for all i know to get a hand job or some
[ __ ] like that
and he goes in there and finds his wife
working in there
so he runs out to the damn car and he
had an sks rifle with a [ __ ] 30
30 round magazine went in there and
killed everybody in there a bit of an
overreaction
and then he killed himself yeah so that
was weird as we were
leaving all we saw was a bunch of
emergency vehicles [ __ ]
coming in on the place that shooting had
just happened we'd heard about it
as we were leaving some weird [ __ ]
so somebody might be able to understand
what the exact date that was i know
i could tell you exactly what the date
was it was my ets date
september 24 1994. that's when that
[ __ ] was
so you checked that yeah anyway it was
two days before my 22nd birthday yeah
so eric you know he got out two days
before i did but he just hung out in the
barracks and party for two days
they didn't make him go anywhere yeah
you know so yeah
so we laughing this dude was a [ __ ]
trip man he was yuppy as hell
we were kind of like opposites he was a
yuppie kid and
he he walked around like a [ __ ]
millionaire he had rolexes and [ __ ]
all this real nice [ __ ]
he's like i only want to buy it once so
i'll just spend you know a bunch of
money on it and keep it from my whole
life he was like one of those kind of
guys
oh yeah yeah you were talking about yeah
that [ __ ] is wearing like damn tweed
coats of [ __ ] look like [ __ ] rex
harrison and [ __ ]
[ __ ] was funny and uh
so we we pull in you know and i kind of
[ __ ] you know hang on my girlfriend
for a while once we get there you know
at her place and then we go out later on
you know and i forgot where eric went
he had a friend in that area too and
then like a couple days later
we jump in his car so we go we and we go
to a real a real estate agent
and we we told her we said we want a
really good deal like on some kind of a
house for like short money
and uh we don't really care what it
looks like as long as it's livable
you know like a really good dish because
i know it's placed just like this
and when we get there as a house it was
like a three-story house with a basement
and [ __ ] was like a hundred something
years old
all right it was an old new england
house and it's
and it was in a bad area it was like
i'm saying it was in a good neighborhood
but i was just saying it was behind the
damn liquor store it was
built before the city was there so it
ended up in like this weird like
cul-de-sac
behind a damn liquor store within
walking distance of a liquor store
that's a great location
you could open the window and [ __ ]
reach out and throw a bottle cap on the
back of the damn
store i mean it was like right up next
to it like a house so [ __ ] man you could
probably just yell out the window hey
bring me some tequila yeah anyway
there was a bunch of weird [ __ ] about
that house we paid first
and last month i think in like a deposit
okay yeah that's usually and then
we stayed there for like seven or eight
months almost a year i think might have
been around 10 months and
no no one ever collected any rent from
us
we didn't even know who is like there's
something really spooky
yeah i don't even know who owned it okay
so but you went through a real estate
yeah and it was the last time we saw her
and and we didn't know who to pay see
that's the opening of the world
movie that sounds like a horror movie it
was some weird [ __ ]
in fact i might not almost skip the
whole [ __ ] weird paranormal story and
go to the end how we got out of there
is one day a dude [ __ ] knocked on the
door and said hey how you doing and
introduced himself since i just bought
this house
was that really you guys like eight
months later yeah and he goes
i didn't realize it but i guess we were
like the house was
for sale yeah you know what i mean but
we never met the damn
landlords they must have moved away yeah
so i think the real estate agent was
kind of like
using us as security guards maybe
yeah to make sure some stuff in here
yeah
and and because we didn't know anyway
because i just bought the house and you
guys are here
and he goes uh i'm gonna start
rebuilding on the bottom floor could you
guys move up into some of the other
floors you know that was nice and i was
like yeah
or no he moved down the middle floor
that's what it was he moved on the
middle floor i moved up the very
i was already up at the very top but he
didn't care
and then like a couple weeks later once
he got [ __ ] done he goes okay you guys
gotta leave
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] so we got kicked
out anyway
anyway um the house was weird
when you walked in there it felt kind of
like
uh somebody was watching you it reminded
me of mammoth mountain a lot yeah
eric didn't believe me that paranormal
[ __ ] but i could tell it was [ __ ]
it was that remember i told you they
said that um
you know on one of our other shows i
said that i lived in a house that was
kind of
like um an old victorian house and none
of the rooms the orders didn't make
sense yeah you walked through
everybody's room that was in detroit
that's why i moved it
no that was in boston no that was in
boston okay that's why i moved up to the
[ __ ] attic apartment because
we couldn't live on the same floor yeah
because you'd be walking through each
other's [ __ ] all the time
yeah so i lived in the very top one and
it had like two rooms
and then i went downstairs to to use the
bathroom on the middle floor
and that middle floor had and the layout
didn't make any sense
yeah but i always had a feeling i was
being watched in there
um if i'd walk around the corner and
walk up on eric he jumped sky-high i
said what's up man you scared
no no no i'm scared you know what i mean
he was afraid to be in there
yeah our dates had come over and you'd
have to walk them to the bathroom
and guard them outside the bathroom
because they were
[ __ ] creeped out by the place but it
looked like a perfectly
good victorian house i mean it was in
good shape
you know yeah when that dude came in to
rebuild it he was knocking those walls
out to try to make some kind of a order
to make it like a normal house yeah make
it like a normal house you know because
he wanted to separate the floors and
then rent out right now
yeah you know to them because you really
couldn't rent it the way it was
i guess that's why and and like what was
weird is that i think we were going to
end up paying like
700 a month which is like amazingly
cheap for boston yeah that's right
that's like [ __ ]
one-third and they never collected any
rent they just took that first last
month and then that deposit i think the
you know the real estate agent probably
took half of that she probably lied to
us about how much this [ __ ] actually
cost anyway
and i don't think the person that owned
the house knew that we were even there
if you asked me i think the re
only the real estate people knew that's
kind of i think it was a side thing that
they had
i think now you know well maybe they
told me
the house was for sale and if they knew
if they were handling the sale of the
house and they knew that the owners were
not in town anymore then yeah
and i think they thought that was going
to be vacant for a year or two yeah
so the real estate agents agents were
going to make some money on the side
instead of hiring securities so [ __ ]
vagrants didn't break in they just have
us up in there and
the thing is they never collected
anything that's what i mean you'd think
that they was just
that first and last in the deposit so
let's rent every month i see get some
extra i think it was just that first and
the last in the positive was enough for
her
maybe she another thing that could
happen is that maybe she switched
jobs after that oh yeah so that she's so
you know we never saw him again
it was just so weird yeah weird yeah
and um the weird thing and then weird
[ __ ] would happen in the house
like um i had bad nightmares
yeah i had a dream that i'd rolled
over my bed and looked down at the floor
that was up in the very top and that i
saw through
all the floors of the house and that i
could see through all the pipes
and then uh down in the pipes i could
see big old piles of [ __ ] starving
little puppies in the pipes
yeah i remember you telling me that was
that was one and that one [ __ ] woke
me up uh yeah
another one that happened was is uh was
dating a girl named alexandria
and all right at the foot of my bed
up against the wall it had a slope
roof and the wall on that one side of
the room
was only about three or four about three
feet tall you know i'm talking about
because of the slope to the roof
and in that wall was a door a little
access door and it was where storage
could go
and for some reason in the middle of the
night that door
started to creak open and i went to try
to shut it like that
in my sleep and uh
alexander's like what is it what is it
and i said that's where it lives
and i said that kind of in my sleep but
what was weird is it opened up
and it had a normally it had like a
latch
and i thought that latch was i don't
know why but it started to open and
creak
open and i just out of a dead sleep went
trying to
shot it what is it what is it that's
where it lives
i said it was you've seen me when i'm
waking up
yeah he says all kind of [ __ ] asleep
that's not as bad as it used to be but
you used to talk in your sleep all the
time and i thought you like you talked
and i thought you were awake because i'd
be like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
now on the other side out in between the
two rooms where they had a staircase
that went up to the top
and in that little entryway in between
the two main rooms was a closet
and i'd been using that closet and it
had like uh
we have sheetrock here all right but in
in a victorian house sometimes it's wood
like wood paneling
but it looked like inch wide stripes
yeah the paneling
i know what you're talking about yeah
but it was like not that cheap [ __ ] you
used to see in the 70s this is like
stuff from the 20s
yeah well on the back of that wall i had
a bunch of coat racks and it had that
striped
wood pattern and as i was hanging up a
coat one time i noticed that
at the very edges all right where those
little
one-inch stripes were is there was
actually a crack and i went this is a
panel this panel removed
yeah so i was pretty spooked i mean i
called eric he was down there i said man
get up here look at this there's a
secret door in here
because i pulled it a little bit and it
moved i wanted him to hold the
flashlight
so i take all the coats down and i open
it and it's just an open
it just opened up you could see the the
underside of the roof
you know and i looked and didn't see
anything down either side
and i uh i said give me that flashlight
and i [ __ ] shone down one way and it
went all the way to the side of the
house well all the way down the side of
the house and it just ended in a wall
nothing you could see rafters you know
then i shone through the other side it
went all the way down at the end and at
the end was a cardboard box
about this big but i felt my foot by
foot and i went oh
[ __ ] look at that box
[Laughter]
what's in the ball yeah so we're gonna
do you see that box
that box must have been about 50 60 feet
down
which is a long way you know what i mean
it didn't have a flat roof it was
you know crooked because yeah and i had
to walk across the rafters
to get to it and i'm thinking and and
eric's like you know there's a baby in
there you know there's these [ __ ] i
would have thought
severed head but maybe he was baby
that's a good thing you know there's a
baby in there
and i'm [ __ ] walking across the
rafters yeah across the raptors to this
[ __ ] box
and it's [ __ ] you know how the top
that cardboard box is folded
uh-huh you know how many people fold it
i said somebody put this [ __ ] here
and i picked it up it was light well i
didn't want to open it there
so i carried it all the way back we
opened it and it was empty just had a
newspaper in it
and a newspaper was like from the 60s
that's some weird [ __ ] man i wonder what
was in this see this is like horrors
because you know i write horror stories
and it's like one of the things that i'm
always fascinated with is like finding
secret rooms or like finding something
where or finding a box or something like
that finding something where
you don't know why it's there see this
is why and i think i talked about this
when we were talking about that roman
polanski movie the tenant
like the part where he like finds the
hole in the wall and there's a [ __ ]
tooth
in there yeah that freaks me
out it kind of culminated into this one
thing where
i was in there by myself one time and i
felt like there was somebody watching me
from
[ __ ] corner to damn room and it kind
of reminded me of the [ __ ] mammoth in
a way and looked and i couldn't see
anything there
but it was so strong i was afraid to
look at it and it just got more and more
like oppressive
and you know what i mean i just felt
like it was crushing me you know i was
like
ah get out of here and you know i know
it's what i went and it just kind of
dissipated
and um i asked eric i said man you feel
like that
feeling of being watched he's like no no
no what are you talking about what are
you talking about no
and i said dude there's something in
this house he goes let's go shooting and
he [ __ ] grabbed 30 carbine and i
grabbed the [ __ ] ak
and we started opening fire and down the
basement
i guess no one else was around we were
scared he was scared shitless because
let's go shooting
and i said yeah i chased the evil
spirits away we [ __ ] bore a hole in
the side of a down wall about a foot in
diameter shooting that [ __ ] armor
was the guy that bought the house
thought about that yeah what are you
doing down here
shooting that [ __ ] steel core ammo
in there man [ __ ] ricochet is
bouncing around inside the damn
[ __ ] yeah but you know what's funny
is like
i felt that that thing was in there it
wasn't as strong as mammoth mountain but
i knew it was in there
yeah and one time i remember [ __ ]
yelling at it
out loud a bit you know what i mean that
uh like i can't get to you but i'll burn
this [ __ ] house down and that's all
you got and that kind of
dissipates he's like all right just back
up yeah he says i'll burn this [ __ ]
house down it's not mine i don't give a
[ __ ]
and that kind of gotta so they respond
to threats that's good to know
yeah it wasn't my house i said this is
your house i will burn it the [ __ ] down
you know who we are you know yeah
because he was watching us but i don't
know what it
i don't know it it responded like it was
kind of conscious to what we were doing
yeah but you see it was real elusive it
wasn't like mammoth mountain where we're
moving on where it you saw stuff
happening yeah no it was just
feeling bad dreams uh an oppressive
feeling of being watched
um the door opening yeah that door
opened and
i can't say that that was paranormal
though i didn't see
i don't know if it was locked it usually
is right
it's just weird you know what i mean it
happened in my sleep it just it might
have been wind i don't know
yeah um but when you had
when i had uh alex over she wouldn't
walk through the house by herself
this house is [ __ ] creepy and i
tried to play it off yeah i mean i
didn't want to you know
i was trying to get laid here you know i
mean i don't want to try to scare her
you know
i'm just going oh it's okay it's just an
empty house
yeah yeah but it was fun but they always
say in horror movies it was [ __ ]
creepy it was it wasn't
they always say to the girls there's
nothing in it there's nothing in here
don't worry about it imagine i had to
wait outside while she's taking a leak
walk around the house you know it's
funny because an air could jump sky high
every time you like yeah and it's
because like i knew he i knew it was
because he felt like something yeah it
felt like someone's watching him but he
was
totally not into the paranormal [ __ ]
that's not happening
but i could see it in him you know it's
weird the only time in my whole life and
i
might have mentioned this to show show
before but i think i've told you
the only time i met other than the
poltergeist [ __ ] we had happened here um
you know just like a couple years ago
the only time i felt that oppressive
something is in here
something is looking at me i have to get
out of here was in a [ __ ] big lots
and i was just in the aisle like looking
at tupperware or something all of a
sudden i was like
what the [ __ ] i gotta get out of here
you know what i mean that's the only
time that i've had that
and i did i was like okay i'm getting
the [ __ ] out of here but the weird thing
about it is that
i spent a lot of time um you know when
we lived for a little while in my
grandfather's old house
in daytona beach it's not there anymore
it got torn down it's a frat house now
uh i think but uh it's i don't know when
it was built early night
early uh 20th century i think it was on
ridgewood
and it was a really cool house like an
old stucco like mansion
and um after my grandmother left him
he became a hoarder as i've mentioned
before so the house was kind of just
like full of crap
and sometimes like when my family was
you know having financial problems or
something we would move in and we would
live on the second floor for a little
while
and all of my um all of my mom's
siblings
had grown up in that house that was like
their childhood home
every single one of them said it was
haunted they said that um we used to
have our blankets pulled off we used to
have
we used to hear like uh somebody walking
around on the roof like all the time
they heard they said it sounded like a
sea captain almost like a sea captain
like walking back and forth like the
deck of a ship
they said that's what it reminded them
of and the weird thing is that i lived
there for a really long time and i kept
and i was like really into like you know
horror and stuff like that like i still
am and i kept hoping it's like oh i want
to see a ghost i want to hear something
but i never did
but i still love that house and i
actually like some of my
fictional stories i still set it in
there because what i was saying about
the secret door before
was one of the coolest things that
fascinated me about this house so much
was that
you there was like a big living room and
then there was like in the kitchen
you turned like in the kitchen and then
there was like a staircase like there
was three steps and then
a landing and then it went up to the
second floor and
right there on the landing was like a
little door
like a little metal door and for a long
time when i was growing up
i'd never seen it open so i didn't know
what was
in there yeah um so i kind of had all
these like fantasies like imagination
like about what was in there and turned
out all that was in there was my
grandfather was a jeweler
and um he kept like all his um you know
all his jewelry and then he had all laid
on tables like a little lab and stuff
and he had like all his lights and
whatnot
but it's like um one story that i wrote
i actually used that
like that there wasn't a door there that
but there was like a secret passage just
because i was so fascinated by that
because i never saw it open and i was
kind of disappointed but i actually did
see it open i'm like ah it's just a room
oh wow i thought it was ak
i thought it was the ak i shot the
basement up with but it wasn't
i sold the ak it was the it was the mini
30.
because that was during the assault
rifle band and i sold all the aks they
were worth a lot of money the mini 30
wasn't
so you just i can't i can't yeah i only
kept i only ended up keeping the guns
that i couldn't get good money for
yeah which was a ruger gp 100 revolver
a 30 carbine and it was a [ __ ]
universal which is
or uh no it was the universe it was one
of the knockoffs
like it wasn't a real mini mini 30.
excuse me it wasn't a real 30 carbine it
was like a 70s knockoff
and that mini 30 i had a falcon folder
on it looked like a
uh you know folding stock on it gun guys
know what i'm talking about
i couldn't get enough money for those i
just went and kept those
well yeah but it's to shoot that same
round as a ak
it's just crazy i sold all the aka
getting scared of ghosts and so going
down shooting up the
first place it was kind of like well
that's scary
yeah i understood it i understood it
immediately when he did it yeah i
understood it immediately i felt the
same way
it was kind of like how chinese throw
firecrackers scare off evil spirits
yeah it's like that well yeah
well you're trying to make yourself feel
like like you got like you have power
and you have energy over this
just because you don't know what it is
just [ __ ] very oppressive
cold sick feeling like it did not feel
like a poultry it felt like the poultry
guys in terms of like you know
poultry guys felt like it was watching
you but that one was just kind of
it had a higher energy feeling too yeah
this one was just kind of
the only way i can describe it was like
slow
cold and like sick it felt you know what
i mean
it wasn't good
do you remember the address because i'd
be curious to know i know where it is i
could find it on i could find it on um
because i wonder if the guy that bought
it like hadn't especially if he was
renovating because they said
i could find it renovating i could find
it on google earth yeah
um i'm sure i think it was i think the
number on it might have been 311 or
three
i can picture where it was yeah yeah i
knew it at one time
it still cracks me up that they just let
you move in there and you were
essentially just squatting
did you pay other bills like electric or
water that's a weird thing
no um i think i i think the electricity
bill
we paid yeah um
we had a phone line in there we paid
that
yeah but that's usually it had a furnace
you had to add oil too
and this is the weird thing about this
one that's the problem it got cold as
[ __ ] in there random [ __ ] winter and
i said why the hell's
what the [ __ ] is it why is it so [ __ ]
cold in there
and i was like whatever has something to
do with that big old metal thing
downstairs
you didn't know i didn't know what that
was i didn't really look at it you know
i never seen anything like that it's
like this is the [ __ ] 21st century
yeah and it had a
and it was like it looked like a big old
[ __ ] generator
you know the way i remember it's like oh
maybe we should and it was it was
like oh this is a [ __ ] water heater
and you see we had those radiators
yeah you know talking about this
radiator
and it had a [ __ ] fuel
gauge on it and everything that says
this thing's out yeah
well hanging from it was affected what's
that i said well that explains it
why it's so cold in there hanging from
the uh hanging from the side of it was a
tag
and a tag was like from an oil service
that had a phone number on it and
everything
so i called that number and i said yeah
i'm in a house i don't own it
but it had your number on the on this
water heater furnace thing
and he i forgot what they call it it i
knew what it was because it said it on
the thing
yeah this is it's got your number on
there and it says and i'm like i don't
know you know
who owns this house i mean
real estate agents just put us in this
thing and he's like where's the address
i'm giving the address a couple minutes
like yeah yeah yeah i remember that okay
well whatever we'll fill it up
you could fill it up from the outside
you could go in through the damn drive
the driveway and i guess there was like
a spigot and a truck that would fill it
up from the outside
and this is what he goes yeah we'll
we'll build that account
that's what he said i never saw a bill
so it's i guess it wasn't you i guess
maybe they were sending them right to
the owner but like i said
yeah yeah maybe that was just paying
them and being like whatever
yeah it wasn't empty and i never got a
bill or never the
the owner never contacted us or anything
i was just like well
it must not have cost much i guess not
i don't know how much i don't know well
it's like some people own because like
look the the people that own our house
that we rent from they own what 12
houses yeah it must be something like
that
like in their they're paid for they
don't have mortgages on them they
outright own 12 houses that they rent
out
must have been something like that and
you know they knew who it was and they
said they haven't bought from us in a
long time
that's what that guy said maybe they
were dead yeah he says
well i think i think maybe the winter
before that maybe there was nobody in
there
yeah that was some weird [ __ ] man
because here's another weird thing that
happened
it was winter time and that wasn't when
it was before the winter time when it
first happened
the windows had all kind of warped they
were hand blown glass
so it didn't really look flat yeah
i opened up the damn window one time
and walked away from it and a few hours
later it fell on its own boom
and it busted that window and knocked a
hole it made us
kind of like a spider web in the window
but the center that spider web popped
out about a six inch diameter piece of
glass
so it had around six inch hole in the
glass with a couple little
spider webs on it and i was like oh [ __ ]
it had a screen so i just left it
winter came it got cold as [ __ ] because
it was amityville horror [ __ ] right
there
winter came it got cold as [ __ ] because
there's a hole in the window well yeah
i wasn't gonna replace that damn
hamburgle glass didn't you at least put
like some plastic over it no i know what
i did
but i took a damn old [ __ ] shirt
i said that shirt's warmer than that
glass
yeah see pretty [ __ ] smart
eric was like maybe we should get some
saran wrap and i go man [ __ ] that
and he goes in there it goes that'll
work he's like hey problem solved
yeah that's pretty funny
all right you were ready to wrap it up
that's it so
that was the story of that house yeah
that's all i could tell you about that
he's got lots of stories about various
things yeah but not ghost stuff
not really yeah you just i mean you have
more ghost stories than me obviously but
yeah one time i had to have this i'll
have to have uh somebody on here i was
showing her some other guys
he's a like a retired e8
special forces ranger also a ranger and
his unit was like uh put in charge of
abu ghraib prison
and this is after you know that [ __ ]
happened it was after that
okay after it was after the uh the um
after that scandal happened they moved
his unit in there
he said that place was dripping with
evil more than three-quarters of them
surprisingly and he said one-quarter
three-quarters of a million people
murdered there
and tortured to death over a period of
about 10 years and he saw apparitions
they're not him but other guys too
you know just yeah it's like black
figures but you know it's like i'm not a
huge believer in the paranormal but it's
like some places it's like
you know if any place is haunted it's
yeah that place and that is definitely
they found mass graves there they'd find
[ __ ] rib cages coming up out of the
sand and [ __ ]
um the uh they just walled off whole
parts of the prison because they're just
[ __ ] speckled with blood and [ __ ]
teeth and
they had a damn eye in the ceiling where
you could just put a hook through
there and they'd give the inmates a
[ __ ] noose and tell them to hang
themselves if they wanted to escape
torture and they'd on average you know
each one of those cells
had one dude would hang himself a day
because they were constantly trying to
pack
more guys into it yeah and so they would
just
torture them until they [ __ ] killed
themselves chances of you coming out of
avogadro prison or [ __ ]
back in saddam's era was very slim
but he just said that that place was
[ __ ] evil
that went dark didn't it yeah
not imagine imagine [ __ ]
concentration camps are probably pretty
[ __ ] spooky
well yeah everyone i've known that has
gone to them like
germany and poland and stuff like that
that have been to them said yeah it's
like super super creepy
and there's like a lot of people go to
them now because it's like kind of like
a weird creepy tourist attraction
yeah um but yeah everybody i know that
has been there said it was like yeah
it's crazy during the time during the
time he was there abu ghraib was
you know it was manned and they were
doing stuff out of there but they just
said it was just unlivable
just the [ __ ] the oppressive feelings
you know and they're using the same
showers that the inmates use
oh stuff like that no thank you and some
of the some of the wings of the prison
they just walled them off they didn't
even want to do it like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that yeah
i don't blame them they didn't clean
them i wouldn't even you just yeah you
know you'd think you would just want to
tear the [ __ ] down and just [ __ ] salt
the earth you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah all right so uh let's wrap up
this uh
little third and we'll probably be
talking to y'all again tomorrow the
movie respective goes up tomorrow too so
that's something for you guys to look
forward to also
you